[Musik]
hallo ich bin heuer politik
vertretungslehrer frau königin bremse
tätigen nervenzusammenbruch und nackt
durch die stadt gerannt und hat autos
angezündet weil es uns allen schon mal
passiert
wie auch immer thema heute soziale
medien moment leonie jacqueline hört
nicht zu er schreibt immer eine woche
aller großen parteien noch heute
wahlkampf mit facebook und twitter weil
sie glauben euch dumpfbacken damit zu
erreichen
werkzeug nur weil die kanzlerin podcast
oder markus söder facebook fortsetzen
die sich noch lange mich für junge
wähler ein
also ich denke sie sind so neidisch aus
soll das hervorragend gemachte
internetpräsenz soziale medien sind aber
man muss auch ohne auskommen
so wie wir hier hat mir kein facebook co
wird mittels klargemacht analog du
anfänger
ich hab die werke auf der kutschfahrt
noch ganz analog bekommen
deshalb kann ich auch mit zwei fingern
im dunkeln öffnen noch nicht dunkel das
außerdem haben wir uns früher nicht
ständig fotografiert wie er der natur am
samstag ist auch lena profis wie
besoffen eingeschlafen und ihr team aber
mit einigen himmel ins gesicht gemalt
[Gelächter]
ich wünsche der waz-gruppe deiner mutter
früher konnte man sich noch daneben
benehmen
ich erinnere mich an einen abend
sowie die höll
ok
[Musik]
hätten wir gesagt
der esel und man kann mir nichts
nachweisen weil es noch keine fotohandys
gab wie geil ist das denn der verband
jetzt mit politik und facebook zu tun
keine ahnung jedenfalls glaubt nicht
alles was politiker im internet erzählen
so liegt er als neue kundin in
wirklichkeit ganz aus hausaufgabe bis
morgen kostet auch markus söder
facebook-seite mindestens 20 kommentare
in denen diverse und cool peinlich und
vollidiot vorgaben
[Musik]